today i'm joined by senator cardin ben
cardin lisa slotkin and the congressman
victoria spots sparts excuse me who uh
i was just talking to her about i still
haven't family back in ukraine god i
love you
i uh
i'm about to sign a bill that these
folks are responsible and of course the
vice president excuse me
the um
i'm signing a bill that provides another
important tool in efforts to support
the government of ukraine and the
ukrainian people and their fight to
defend their country uh and their
democracy against putin's brutal war and
it is brutal
i want to thank members of congress here
for getting this passed and everyone who
supported the bill
and the bill demonstrates the support
for ukraine is pivotal at this moment
every day ukrainians pay with their
lives and they fight along with
the atrocities that
the russians are engaging in are just
beyond the pale
and the cost of the fight is not cheap
but uh caving to aggression is even more
costly that's why we're staying in this
yesterday we celebrated ve day victory
in europe day marking the end of a
transition
of
the devastation after the consequence of
world war ii
and allied nations defeated the scourge
of fascism in europe
and today europe is honoring another
important day
on anniversary on may 9th 1950 just
years after the end of world war ii
europe began to work to strengthen the
bonds of unity among the nations
particularly economic unity
and the shared economic prosperity the
idea ultimately grew into
the what is now 27 nation european union
an economic powerhouse
and a global force for peace and close
partners
of all on all the issues we face
and it really has uh
i've said from the very beginning it's
something that
is good for everyone it brings these
countries together in ways that when it
cooperates closely economically they
also cooperate in other ways and you've
seen it in their support for ukraine
and with putin's war
once more
bring in one destruction of europe
and to reaffirm the enduring commitment
to the future grounded in democracy
human rights and peaceful resolution of
disagreements i'm now going to sign this
bill
and again i
thank the colleague for standing behind
me and
because it really matters it matters
there you go
done
[Applause]